About the four write
methods in Firebase.
But it sounds like you want to read
from the Firebase database as well.
It's time to become
fully Firebase literate.
Reading data in Firebase
is all about Listeners.
You set a Listener and then define what
it does whenever it receives new data or
changes to existing data.
It's always triggered
with initial data and
then it is triggered again whenever
there is new or changed data.
There are three ways to add
read Listeners in Firebase.
AddValueEventListener receives
events about changes to data
at a specific location.
AddChildEventListener receives events
about changes in the child locations of
a given Firebase reference.
It is useful when trying to
keep track of lists of data.
The third method is
addListenerForSingleValueEvent.
AddListenerForSingleValueEvent looks
almost exactly like addValueEvent
Listener.
But it does only one
read when you make it.